just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world in Florida news oh was good some
of our favorite oh great it's very
interesting three South Florida men are
facing Federal kidnapping charges after
they allegedly abducted the wrong man oh
and then proceeded to waterboard him
inside of a local Airbnb R the wrong guy
yeah Florida's close to guantan Mo Bay
do you think that these are agents wait
like three undercover agents well cuz I
don't know like man you cracked the C
outside of the government I don't really
see water boarding as a technique that
just regular everyday people use you
know is water boarding where they put
the towel over your face and they pour
it feels like they drowning simul drown
[__] the Crips don't do that [__] how
long do they they just do the normal
[__] yeah [__] waterboard is crazy
whip maybe it's a Florida you chop off
fingers fingernails you beat them up can
I just say though it's kind of stupid
that they did it at Airbnb because you
got caught because you have to sign up
and do the thing yeah you have your real
profile yeah you think the profile
picture was them with their family these
guys also got the wrong guy so I think
there's a string of dumbness that goes
in play yeah and why'd you do it at
Airbnb he's a FSE cuz you have to pay
for the water yeah that's true oh
what yeah and they probably have like
nice towels Ryan's a wild guy it takes a
lot of water to simulate
drowning Federal prosecutors claimed
that on the evening of October 13th
Brothers Jeffrey and Jonathan Arista and
Raymond Gomez snatched the man as he was
leaving his Fort Lauderdale home damn
the trio forced him into a white Dodge
Charger with Sham police lights
blindfolded him and transported him to a
rental unit in Plantation which is the
name of the town
uh to shake him down for cash they
claimed to be owed according to the
arrest affidavit and he's like it's not
me you got the wrong guy one of the
kidnappers was disguised as a police
officer wearing a gold badge and a
tactical vest shortly after arriving at
the Airbnb the kidnappers realized they
mistakenly kidnapped their intended
targets coworker oh no oh so they've
been studying a guy that they're like oh
this guy has money we need to kidnap him
but they got the coworker instead
apparently it was money owed to them oh
oh so they even get hired cuz that's how
stupid they are if they were hired and
they got the wrong target then it's like
oh mistakes but they've been staking out
which guy they want and then they don't
know until they got there and then
rather than freeing the man the the trio
tortur him by pointing guns at his head
placing a power drill to his skin Oh
[__] tring to kill him and then water
boarded him we on the skin yeah does it
say so were they like that's a great
question was it on the I like that
question on the elbow it says four skin
on the penis no it doesn't nobody gives
a [__] about that question okay I'm
sorry man I thought it was a good
question curious if they knew it was the
wrong guy like before they tortured him
how come they just was it is it more
like I got him already so might as well
kind of um they ended up just basically
torturing him to be like where's the
right guy oh my gosh well how would he
know it's a coworker where's your
coworker that's like I they ask all the
time where's Bart like when I'm just
chilling they're like where's Bart and
I'm like that's really funny family that
is always the funniest question be awaii
you're in V dude if someone abducted me
to find out where Joe is I'm [__]
dead dude I don't even know where this
guy is I think that's that's a way of
people feeling like they're relating at
a quicker level than just saying hi I'm
a fan next time if someone goes where's
Bart I'm just going to call Bart just
call me and I just be like hey dude uh
so this this guy is asking for you and
then I bark and talk to him they're
going to love that so I wouldn't have
said that cuz now you're going to get
people asking just ktie I'll kick you in
the balls if you
ask said it you said his
boundary imagine if I was like Hey guys
if you see me on the street don't be shy
say what's up but if you ask for Bart
I'll kick you in the [__] balls and
then no one like the person didn't watch
this video right so then they go Hey Joe
what's up where's Bart and I go bow and
he like what
like oh you watch spread the news what
if they have no
balls if it's a lady yeah oh [__] you
got to figure out alternative kick kick
her man's balls I'll kick any male yet
you're standing next to a male in a 5
foot primer you trying to say ladies
can't have balls oh caught him yeah oh
you are a republican I hate you you
[__] transphobic [__] a republican
in the mon as a member of the lgbtq uh
Community I hate you you're in a you're
a member in lgbtq I am which part which
which I identify as a straight lesbian
oh I'm so confused so am I so am
I I'm giving him the floor to explain
Jason what's a straight lesbian check it
out hello yeah hello are you still on
that side [__] you heard glossy
boy what you see is what you get brother
how you feel about it what you see what
dude that explanation would fix so much
confusion in the
world but can you question it if you
question it does that mean you're you're
not an ally yeah you don't do that
you're a don't do that you ain't a
[__] Ally dude I don't know um why
people got to be so intolerant these
days but for me I think it's pretty
simple all I'm asking people to do is
just call me by what I want to be called
yeah which is also straight lesbian
straight lesbian but also if I didn't
know what your your pronouns are and I'm
a little bit [__] then you got to
educate me you can't be like you [__]
homophobic [__] yeah that's true that's
true mean true you got to tell
me do you know what I mean okay you got
to tell me the thing you got to educate
me you can't put me on game say that
yeah say put me on game put me on game
now people need to go to Joe at June B
they can't ask where his bar otherwise
they'll get kicked in the nuts and they
got to call him a straight lesbian
straight lesbian if they didn't watch
this video they're [__] they're [__]
dude this is a really important video
for JK you should just have it playing
on the monitor at Jun be so people know
I know I bet our sales would go really
high we're the opposite I don't know
what happened but uh one day I went up
to my store and there was a big uh
rainbow flag there and huh um I just
decided to keep it and I think from that
point on I knew that I had to really
become who I really was yeah you know
where your peoples are yep is there
really a rainbow flag at your
store there is is that for Hawaii though
or is that for it could be both he's
like Dam I don't know I don't know where
it came from my employees I don't know
if a gift like a like a customer came
and they put it there but it's there now
and I and to me it's just instead of
throwing that away and saying don't put
anything up there you burn it no I just
embraced
it Embrace yeah embrace you embrace the
flag and also Embrace a new gender ex so
what if somebody like goes there and
puts like a Confederate flag up I have
to embrace it what if they what if they
put a K's
flag I have to embrace it wow that's
super mature
gr the way he said I have to embrace it
was less wanting yeah but the words were
all still there so if somebody were just
typing this out like a stenographer it
would be the same [__] but he was saying
it with his mou it would be 10 fonts
smaller it would be they don't do that
cuz it's too it's a typewriter no no
they they have they have a reluctant
font by the way out of everyone here I I
wear the kja shirt the most so what if
somebody put a boba time flag go ahead
and take that away it's like take it
back it's like I wear the careful Boy
shirt bro you you never give me one plug
you're supposed to like follow up with
one of those it's in the linkoln bio in
the description like Joe does yep
there's a hey everyone's wearing a
careful Boy shirt except for you yours
is the sounds gay I'm
in he's the one and this is the other
dude that hooking us all up and stuff
shirts buddy is a great shirt Gio gave
me this shirt yeah GI gave us these
shirts really true yeah
Gian that's his name
on is that gian's company not white okay
not white well I'm okay buddy thank you
shout outs to you guys but you're
overshadowed by the careful boys
t-shirts cuz that's what we're going to
promote but thank you thank you very
much it's very polite I I got some I got
some merch too again coming from the
sounds gay I'm in guy I'm I got some
buddy merch too I'm just not wearing
it cool do you have any merch that you
want to plug Jason chenny no do you have
Jason chenny merch yeah yeah what's the
when you don't have Jason chenny merch
like that's so nice I do but it's all
sold out Jesus are you [__] kidding
me it sold out because I didn't make it
can I make it for
you what make it you have to have a
shirt that going make it I'm going have
a shirt that says that's so nice man I'm
going to make it that's the best thing
okay that's so nice and then fear
everybody yep no you we already have
that [__] dude but be no everyone he has
he has fear everybody Fe how about fear
how about fear anyone you no off
yeah bootleg yeah like a bootleg fear
some fear some some guys some guys some
some young guys fear some guys some some
straight
[Laughter]
[Music]
lesbian h